(upbeat rock music)
- Hey!
♪ Like the latest fashion ♪
♪ Like a spreading disease ♪
♪ The kids are strappin' on
their way to the classroom ♪
♪ Getting weapons with
the greatest of ease ♪
♪ The gangs stake out
their own campus locale ♪
♪ And if they catch you slippin' then ♪
♪ Well, it's all over, pal ♪
♪ If one guy's colors and
the other's don't mix ♪
♪ They're gonna bash it up ♪
♪ Bash it up, bash it up, bash it up ♪
♪ Hey, man, you talkin' back to me ♪
♪ Take him out, you gotta
keep 'em separated ♪
♪ Hey, man, you disrespecting me ♪
♪ Take him out, you gotta
keep 'em separated ♪
♪ Hey, hey, they don't pay no mind ♪
♪ If you're under 18 you
won't be doing any time ♪
♪ Hey, hey, come out and play ♪
- Whoo!
♪ By the time you hear the siren ♪
♪ It's already too late ♪
♪ One goes to the morgue
and the other to jail ♪
♪ One guy's wasted and
the other's a waste ♪
♪ It goes down the same
as the thousand before ♪
♪ No one's getting smarter,
no one's learning the score ♪
♪ Your never-ending spree of
death and violence and hate ♪
♪ It's gonna tie your own rope ♪
♪ Tie your own rope, tie your own ♪
♪ Hey, man, you disrespecting me ♪
♪ Take him out, you gotta
keep 'em separated ♪
♪ Hey, man, you talkin' back to me ♪
♪ Take him out, you gotta
keep 'em separated ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, they don't pay no mind ♪
♪ If you're under 18 you
won't be doing any time ♪
♪ Hey, hey, come out and play ♪
- Whoo!
(audience cheering and clapping)